ce qui a l'air d'une simple réparation
est un véritable entraînement pour lui
arnaud est carrossier peintre depuis
cinq ans dans ce garage est dans son
domaine il a déjà un joli palmarès
il ya deux ans j'avais déjà fait premier
bourgogne franche comté et 4e france
avec médaillons d'excellence
donc si je t'ai le plus jeune
participant donc cette année j'ai pu et
peut pas parce que tu as une chance un
titre national qui lui ouvre grand les
portes des mondiaux des métiers là bas
il retrouvera une connaissance franc
comtoise
adrien étudiants microtechnique en école
d'ingénieurs à besançon il est en
alternance dans cette manufacture
horlogère depuis un an et demi
lui aussi est un compétiteur né au point
de prendre son travail comme un
divertissement
ma vision du travail cit obtiendrait les
totalement changé puisque avant je
faisais du dessin peut-être quatre
heures par semaine en cours et petit à
petit en fait on commence à faire ça et
bas au lieu de 4 heures c'est bien 8 par
semaine et puis après ça devient le sort
chez soi ça devient le week-end c'est
bien regarder des infos sur internet
aller chercher plus loin et du coup
aussi à force est plus vraiment un
travail mais plus une occupation en
septembre dernier
adrien a rajouté une ligne dans son cv
vice-champion d'europe de dessin
industriel
un résultat qui n'est dû qu'à son
travail et son envie d'apprendre
toujours plus qualité qu'il partage avec
son collègue carrossier on a qui sont
touchés
point barre et lui on voit qu'il veut de
par ses concours ces championnats les
plus longues montrer ce qu'il sait faire
c'est comme un skieur de fond qui fait
les courses régionales ou ceux qui
veulent monter plus haut lors des
mondiaux arnaud s'attaquera des
véhicules bien plus endommagé que celui
ci côté dessin adrien sera en
concurrence avec les meilleurs jeunes de
la planète
mais son patron n'est pas inquiet adrien
il a une capacité
d'apprentissage qui est très rapide il
ya une vision et une vision 3d
dans l'espace qui est impressionnante et
qui permet justement de pouvoir agir
très rapidement et comprendrez
rapidement les choses
aujourd'hui ça fait 18 ans que dans
l'horlogerie et j'ai jamais c'est la
première fois que je vois quelqu'un qui
construit aussi rapidement
des éléments adrien et arnaud
s'envoleront fin août avec la délégation
française pour kazan ou du monde équipe
de france russie
si l'on se réfère à l'été 2010 8 toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour
décrocher une nouvelle étoile